th out your corpsicle we have a ton of
new Clues to help us solve true
detective's latest case from Travis's
surprising connection to season 1's rust
Cole the mysterious spiral found in both
seasons and a shocking piece of
information that links the cultists of
season one with the salow scientists and
what about that mine could it be behind
all the seemingly Supernatural
occurrences going on in town we'll dive
into all that but before we begin take a
moment to like the video and leave a
comment I'm just as in the weeds as you
guys are and I love to hear new and
exciting theories episode 2 begins right
where we left off detective Liz Danvers
alongside Pete prior investigate the
aptly named corpsicle comprised of six
bodies of the salal research scientists
Frozen together in the most disturbing
ice sculpture since the time I allowed
my nephew to make a snowman you may
recall that there are eight members of
This research team so where are the
other two first unaccounted for is
Raymond Clark the man who announced
she's at the beginning of episode one
then there's Anders Lun sala's Project
Lead and founder who's miraculously
pulled alive from the ice we saw Anders
briefly at the whiteboard in episode 1
Liz learns that emergency surgery will
have to be performed on him before he
can be questioned that is if he even
makes it while not impossible the fact
someone survived this is pretty insane
there have been Miracle stories of
people trapped in ice and surviving for
hours and we don't exactly know how long
these guys have been out there while
they went missing 4 days ago it doesn't
necessarily mean they froze 4 days ago
the bodies also suffer from three
distinct injuries the first are these
burnt corneas there are two main ways
you can burn your corneas one is through
UV light and the other with intense heat
since there's no sun up here we're left
with a few guesses as to what may have
caused this injury including lasers
metal work tools flood lamps or molten
metal and chemicals hitting the eye the
only place around town that I imagine
would have stuff like this is the mine
and I'll argue throughout this video
that the mine is at the center of all
the weird occurrences going on in town
and these weird occurrences may have
something to do with the town's water
the second set of injuries are ruptured
eard drums this could be the result of a
sudden change in pressure or Extremely
Loud sounds unequal air pressure is
something that's not uncommon in mind so
yet another clue to add to our list
finally there's these self-inflicted
wounds to the body most likely the
result of delirium Peter brings up
what's called called paradoxical
hypothermia in which people in the cold
get so delirious that they take off
their clothes thinking they're warm this
might also explain whether clothes were
neatly folded and left off to the side
did they do this on their own accord or
was there a killer involved on Anders is
this spiral mark on his forehead this
marking becomes the biggest clue in
linking the scientist's death with that
of Annie Koto 6 years ago it's also
something that was associated with a
devil worshipping cult in season 1 got
this uh brand on his back like in a
spiral he says that's their sign they
they they sacrifice kids and whatnot
something about some place called
carcosa and the yellow King now you
might be curious why he kept in this
mention of carcosa and the yellow King
remember that quote at the beginning of
episode one by hildred castain well
hildred is a fictional character who's
obsessed about a play called The King in
Yellow in it is a mythical land called
carcosa where everyone is under the
spell of this King and haunted by
something called the yellow sign what if
this is all a metaphor for NS Alaska NIS
is carcosa the spiral is the yellow sign
and the people are under the spell of
the mine whether they know it or not
spirals can also be found in the bodies
of some of the victims found in season
one but back to this connection between
Raymond Clark and Annie last episode we
saw Raymond wear the same exact coat as
Annie and in this episode we learned
that the two were lovers he has a spiral
tattoo on his chest to match that of
Annie this puts Raymond as the prime
suspect in Annie's murder and
conveniently enough he just so happens
to be missing from the corpsicle while
interviewing the station's cleaning lady
and delivery guy Liz and Navaro get a
grim picture of Clark a man who would
stare at nothing walk around naked lock
himself in his room and often be heard
crying something was definitely not
right Clark bought a trailer over 7
years ago presumably to have a place to
hang out with Annie away from the base
now this could be a shot in the dark but
it's possible this trailer once belonged
to rust as Chuck here said it used to
belong to his cousin who died of bone
cancer it's hinted that in True
Detective season 1 a part of the reason
rust came back from Alaska to solve the
case was that he wanted to make things
right before he died we left something
undone we got to fix it he didn't fear
death because he knew he was already
dying and if it was bone cancer it would
be the same type as his father I'm sure
someone will tell me if this is
impossible in the comments the delivery
guy even says he felt like someone was
there with him when he discovered that
the scientists were missing and if we
pause here someone definitely was and if
you stick around to my trailer soothing
section I'm pretty sure I know who it is
but why would Clark need a trailer if he
was the only researcher who had his own
room why did his relationship with Annie
have to be a secret last episode Rose
told Navaro that it was Travis who led
her to these bodies but Travis died
years ago choosing to kill himself in
the ice rather than and slowly die to
leukemia this is a completely different
story than what we get in Season 1 we
learned that Travis is rust CO's father
and while interviewed we learned this
about his dad near as we could tell his
pops never had leukemia no hospital
records of that back nobody in that town
Alaska seen Travis col more than 30
years so on one hand we have Rose saying
they had this great time together
cuddling before he died and on the other
we have detectives that say he hasn't
even been there for 30 years according
to rust his biological mother left him
in Travis when he was 2 years old
prompting them to move to Alaska this
would imply that Rose isn't Russ's
biological mother but the
inconsistencies in the story here make
rose an unreliable narrator I think
there's more going on with her mental
health than what's being portrayed we
see that she takes marijuana whether
it's recreational or medicinal is
unknown but I'm inclined to believe her
vision of Travis is a figment of Her
Imagination induced by some combination
of her mental health drugs or even the
town's water lots of our characters have
started to experience flashes from their
past Liz with her son Navar with her
mother and also her time in the military
are these brought upon by the Mind
polluting the town's water supply
causing some sort of mass psychosis or
delirium also why does Rose called
Navaro Missy no one else calls her that
is that just her nickname or is there
something more here to get a better
grasp on what the scientists were doing
at salow Liz questions Bryce a high
school geology teacher and former lover
it's no coincidence that the room is is
filled with images of the Earth's core
in my episode 1 video I theorized that
the Caribou going over the cliff and
lack of crabs in The Season's Harvest
might be the result of the Earth's
shifting magnetic field a field
scientists believe is generated by the
Earth's core and what do we see Bry
talking about when Liz enters the
Earth's core Bryce tells us pretty much
what we already know that the scientists
were working on sequencing DNA from
extinct microorganisms these were found
deep within the ice and when sequenced
might end up during cancer autoimmune
diseases or genetic disorders it's also
possible that these scientists may have
uncovered something deadly Navaro tells
rose that she brought her sister jwes to
Alaska to keep her close last episode it
was implied that their mother suffered
from mental illness and here we get a
frightening flashback of these two
sisters as kids as their mother goes
through a almost possessed episode I
want you to remember this shot right
here when we get to our trailer
sleuthing section it will become clear
why in town is Captain in Connelly
lizz's Superior who promoted her to her
job in Enis last episode Navaro referred
to him as Daddy Connelly hinting that
she knew about their ongoing
relationship how's daddy Conley this has
been a relationship that has been going
on for 19 years Connelly was married
when they first started their Affair but
the episode doesn't explain whether he
was married to Kate mckitrick Kate works
for the mind and is the one who gave the
go-ahead for Liz to use the arena to
house the frozen bodies and she hates
Liz because she slept with her
ex-husband that Connelly wants Liz to
hand over the case and give it to
Anchorage but ultimately at least
according to Liz she gets to take this
on her own eventually teaming up with
her former partner Navaro and Liz used
to work together but something went
terribly wrong prompting Liz to transfer
Navaro to state troopers we get a little
clue that this bad case was the quote
wheeler thing something Liz won't even
let Navaro mention the wheeler thing was
shut up but before clearing the ice for
corpses we get a brief interaction
between Leah and Sherry the 16-year-old
girl she was caught making a sex tape
with last episode I'm not exactly sure
where this is going but Sherry will
later invite her to a closed outdoor slh
hunting shop which opens up some
interesting possibilities Liz probes
Peter on how these scientists were
killed it's almost as if she's training
him to be her Protege she'll tell him
he's not asking the right questions the
same thing she told Navaro when she was
under her wing and it's possible that
the reason Liz is so hard on Peter is
that she wasn't hard enough on Navaro
and look how that turned out one of the
big takeaways from Peter and Liz's
assessment of the bodies is the
possibility of a killer they get these
unidentified fingerprints found on one
of the boots and the folded clothes
suggest someone either made them do this
or folded it themselves Hank's past with
Peter turns out to be a lot more abusive
than originally thought with him
clocking his own son for stealing those
files on Annie cot talk it's still
unknown why Hank is so clingy with these
files but it looks like a bit of karma
is coming Hank's way in the form of his
male order bride Alina from Russia she
needs money for her sick mother money
which Hank is happy to send not
realizing that Alina could just be using
him to get money there may not even be a
sick mother at all Peter has done some
digging to find that salal was funded by
a shell company belonging to tutle
United you may remember the name Tuttle
from season 1 is the influential family
that ruled much of Louisiana it was this
family that ran the cult that Rus and
Marty looked into with this company
funding cell Outlet really calls into
question what they were doing here is
this simply a big company contributing
to The Sciences or is there a more
nefarious plan at work when Liz comes
home and finds Leah getting a temporary
Inu tattoo she is livid it seems
anything to do with Native American
culture she is against we've seen how
she mocks Navarro's beliefs in almost
every scene she's in and you know this
because spirit animal came to you in a
dream this is quite odd since it's
implied Liz was married to Leah's father
Jake who was Native American and had a
son with him so something must have
happened to make Liz burst out like this
and it likely has something to do with
Jake and her son being dead in episode
one Liz feverishly tries to turn off
Ferris bu's day off because it kept
looping The Beatles Twist and Shout not
a Beatles fan but it's not the Beatles
She Hates but the memory associated with
it in this flashback with her son Twist
and Shout plays in the background so if
we use this logic maybe the reason she
doesn't like Leah's tattoo has nothing
to do with a disdain for indigenous
culture but that it reminds her of her
husband and son it was interesting for
Liz to notice Darwin playing with Legos
and in her flashback Legos are on the
ground with her son we also get a brief
introduction to the grandmother who
taught Darwin about this local Legend
the one a picture was drawn of in
episode one Liz shows Navaro Annie's
spiral tattoo credit cards show that 4
days after Annie died Raymond got the
same tattoo over his heart is this the
mourning of a man who lost the love of
his life or of a psychopath who murdered
Annie and now keeps her metaphorically
close to his chest I also love the
little detail of the fantasy football
emails in her inbox something she said
she loves in episode one fantasy
football the lab results from the tongue
found out salow confirmed it was Annie K
and there's no one who knows more about
Annie's case than Navaro so Liz lets her
join in on the case there's this subtle
line here that I love she changed where
you put the cans it implies that Liz and
Navar were once such good friends that
Liz knew where she kept everything in
her kitchen perhaps this case will mend
their relationship and allow Navaro a
chance at Redemption at the rink Leah
visits Peter I like the blue king crab
ad in the background the place Navaro
visited in episode 1 Peter explains that
his father had a rough childhood raised
by an animal which may explain his
violent tendencies combined that with
Peter's mother claiming Hank's dream was
to be a musician but he was never good
enough and a picture starts to form of a
man who has always been put down only to
now take out his anger on his son it
looks like Peter is trying to break this
cycle of abuse and be the dad to Darwin
that his father never was to him while
going through Raymond's files we get a
look at some of the organisms found in
the frozen ice particularly fungi and
bacteria but as Liz delves deeper into
his work strange drawings and writings
can be found check out this page which
has words like I can hear her feel her
moving her cold fingers under the word
her eyes we see these two black spheres
with circles emanating from them while
they do look like they could be eyes if
you believe in this magnetic field
Theory these circles could be the
magnetic fields that emanate from Earth
the woman referred to in these rantings
is most likely Annie it seems like
Raymond is haunted by her which would
align with what Rose said about ghosts
at the beginning of the episode some
come because they miss you some to tell
you they need something or some come to
take you with them but what does Annie
want Liz and Navaro search of Raymond's
trailer uncovers some truly shocking
elements first this place looks as
though it hasn't been touched in years
there's a heavy layer of dust everywhere
and Annie's cell phone is still here
this is something that was never found
on her body so we might get some Clues
from it the table is riddled with animal
bones something that was used to Adorn
victims found in season 1 there are also
these creepy makeshift crosses and
Effigies made out of string yarn and
sticks much like the ones found in
season 1 the roof of the trailer has
this giant spiral and below it is Shrine
to Annie with various photos of her and
Raymond plastered over the walls over
here you can see the words come back so
Raymond either didn't kill her or did
kill her and regrets it so the episode
ends with six out of the eight bodies
thawing out of this corpsicle we have
Annie's cell phone and Anders Lun to be
interviewed which could reveal further
Clues but if you want to know even more
where this story is headed we now plunge
into our trailer sleuthing section where
we take a look at the season's trailers
to find out what might happen next now I
won't be covering every shot just the
ones I think are important for the story
ahead Liz is interviewed by two men
similar to how rust and Marty were in
season 1 is this after the events of the
Season or sometime before remember that
delivery guy from episode 1 claiming he
saw someone well it certainly looks like
he sees a Raymond here wearing Annie's
coat but we can't be 100% sure since
we'll later see this random dude wearing
the same coat later on we have more
spirals at what appears to be an
abandoned Factory of some sort Navaro is
frightened by a naked Jewels is this a
hallucination or is Jewels succumbing to
the same compulsion that the scientists
did who took off their clothes and went
out into the tundra we'll see her drop
this plate of food where she experiences
a bunch of mental trauma Navaro told
jwes she wouldn't send her back to the
lighthouse a clinic to help people with
problems like hers but here we see Jules
being taken away and notice the
lighthouse statue here in the background
we will get to see what happened when Li
and Navaro work together this might be
the quote unquote wheeler case which
resulted in Navaro getting moved to
Troopers we'll see this guy sitting in
front of a woman's dead body could
wheeler be one of these two people and
did Navaro do something that led to them
not saving this woman in time the same
woman can be seen looking quite demonic
here and this looks like the exact same
pose her mentally ill mother did in
episode 2 so this is most likely a
nightmare or hallucination Naro
experiences is this Raymond Clark in
some sort of under Brown bunker we'll
later see this guy dragging Navaro
before he's tied up to this chair at the
salal station one of these dudes has got
to be Raymond right now there is some
really interesting stuff going on with
these protests outside the mine here
we'll see Navaro in riot gear haunted by
a vision of Annie Kay either this is a
flashback or the protests have started
back up again something that was hinted
at in episode two due to the Resurgence
of black water in some of the town's
folks homes and it looks like Leah will
be a part of this protest Dawning the
sponged paint across her mouth just like
Annie K did now there's also this brief
segment where Peter says he has to fix
something and this is Crosscut with
pictures of his father talking about
family and blood if you combine this
with Peter digging a hole in the ice
where you can see a body on a sled in
the background does Peter kill his
father is that Hank in the body bag out
back now I want to end on this shot a
pool of blood on the floor I checked out
the other homes in the season and the
doorway here matches lizz's house but
the legs that come by here look to be
that of a males does a murder take place
here and if so who killed who the only
idea I have at the moment is Peter
killing Hank and maybe it has something
to do over the ank files and the years
of abuse Peter had to endure but now I
turn it over to you what did you think
of episode 2 I want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching be sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram @ thinkstory YT until next
time remember Daddy loves you very
much